welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and our infinity Saga rewatch
turned up meaningful overlooks visual
details in all Twigg three Marvel films
including the subtlety of James Rhodes
wordplay boom you looking for this does
he do it now that I have thoughtfully
re-examined each MCU chapter I'm finally
gonna do a full ranking of the Infinity
saga films something I've avoided
outside of sarcastic tweets
misinterpreted by children because I
prefer appreciation and focusing on what
unites us because I can't make friends
in real life anyway unlike other
rankings based on these subjective wins
of the rankest this blue dungeon nerd
has assigned each movie a numerical
score out of 41 out of 10 across four
categories one story is that a
well-crafted film with a strong somatic
through-line
that movie appreciators outside of
Martin Scorsese would consider cinema
two and see you pay off does it reward
Marvel fans with clever bridge-building
to the rest of the universe
you know fanservice or is it really
skippable 3 action do the highlights wow
us with unforgettable matchups and
stunts and booms and for risk does it
boldly break the mold redeem past
missteps or stick to the easy formulaic
tropes let's count them down but first
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business all right here we go
starting at the bottom number 23 Thor
the dark world
yeah no surprises here right really just
suffered from phase 2 growing pains
awkward rillette 'it's a forgettable
villain in a romance so hollow that the
final kiss was with the stand-in and no
one noticed or cared a thrilling Moki
driven second act could not save a story
that Eminem needed to spend seven
minutes of avengers endgame redeeming
next number 22 Captain Marvel
despite some really fun MCU
contributions with Nick Fury the
tesseract Scrolls just like brie Larson
was struggling to balance Carol Danvers
ego in a story about the vulnerability
of memory any game showed that there's
fun places to go
what the character as a team player with
checks on her power and according to
Brees amazing facial expression there it
seems like that's a direction she wants
to go in the future
number 21 The Incredible Hulk now in my
opinion hoax first reel ensue film is
Avengers which established hoax
evolution to controlled chaos in just a
few great lines that this movie only
kind of hit it was a step in the right
direction from the Angley Hulk but
really there's little reason to re-watch
this other than to research Thunderbolt
Ross Red Hulk Leary's okay those out of
the way we're now taking a big step up
in quality with number 20 or more is
definitely worthy for a cosmic world
building and letting Loki shine bran of
Shakespearean tones were a bit undercut
by some bland action and every shot
looking like the tripod was missing a
leg like I love a good diagonal and
frame but it doesn't have to be the
goddamn horizon onto number 19
might be getting some controversy here
ant-man look Paul Rudd Peyton Reed
Michael Pena gave the MCU a fresh breath
of humor just do not make up for the
bonkers plot folks they took Edgar
Wright's early concept and turn it into
a family man crook killing a murderous
CEO in his daughter's bedroom all
because a senile scientist doesn't trust
his daughter the most competent person
in the movie what that's a punch
now number 18 ant-man and the wasp
improved all this a bit it leaned into
the silliness with a hilarious Big
Lebowski inspired scramble but because
this is all still Marvel this genre
restricted it to what ended up being a
hero story that doesn't really need its
hero
also we got in it this is a real missed
opportunity to make the quantum realm
the emcee use big cavern of mystery
instead of what a ton of being a kind of
plot hole pit number 17 Iron Man 3 is a
much better film than its gaps an MCU
canon make it seem
it shows us both the joy of being broken
but also the crippling pain that comes
with it it it introduces the critical
MCU lesson of the man inside the suit
paving the way for future lessons
similarly number 16 Iron Man 2 shared
the love of Iron Man two forces both
good and evil in a story about paternal
legacy with Iron Man 2 the MCU crawled
out of it's uncertain trial phase into
an upgraded
Proud a cinematic universe boom goes
that dynamite next number 15 Avengers
age of Ultron struggled to live up to
sky-high expectations this incomplete
movie really only makes sense as a first
act set up that introduces themes paid
off an infinity war in an end game its
flaws are lifted by stunning world
building cool collapse and this gym boom
you looking for this
boom which of course that sets up our
favorite running bit that we discovered
in this series from a movie whose
placement might trigger you number 14
Captain America Civil War many of you
may now feel like booms roadies since
the board didn't make my top 10 get it
if we were just going by action and
fanservice this would be in the top 5
the fights are brutal the matchups are
sexy spider-man black panther ant Man's
powers are cool I love it
but Civil War is also kind of a mess
filmmakers really wanted Captain America
3 the studio 1 and Avengers 3 but
clearly no one here wanted a true Civil
War story it was a title used as a bait
and switch that debate is really
superficial no one dies no one learns
anything both heroes are too dumb to
stubborn
Tony lectures everyone about hurting
kids and then immediately enlists a
child because what fanservice look Tony
meeting Peter Parker is one of my
favorite scenes in the MCU but in the
context of this movie it is a
post-credits scene that comes way too
early
ok number 13 guardians of the galaxy vol
2 continues all the great moves from vol
1 killer soundtrack thrilling teamwork
Athy matically rich story about the love
of family versus selfish ego now the
final act does lean a bit too much on
trope for me but hey the way James Gunn
can make us feel for randos like Alan do
is insanely impressive next number 12
Captain America the First Avenger does
not pack quite a punch as stunt work in
its later films but the reframing of
caps history is a self-aware propaganda
tool in the midst of an Indiana
jones-style period adventure set up the
MCU with its best character arc in games
final frames hit so hard because this
movie sticks its landing so perfectly
I had a date number 11 spider-man far
from home heightens Peter Parker's
coming-of-age in a post endgame MCU with
a lot to say about truth media
manipulation Mysterio ranks among the
most effective Marvel villains for the
way his team weaves together MCU past
and present and future expanding the
spider verse and Marvel phase for plot
lines hopefully someday an MCU
spider-man that isn't obsessed with
Ironman okay on to our top 10 MCU films
but first thanks again to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business are you looking for a
website to sell your fan art where you
fix that Airport battle capped America's
Civil War by putting all the rest of the
MCU warriors in there as it should be
well you can present this beautiful work
using Squarespace is professional
portfolio designs display projects and
customizable galleries and add
password-protected pages to share
private work with clients you can also
auto post your content to Twitter
Facebook Tumblr you can easily import
from Instagram Twitter or other
platforms to give your site the personal
visual flair that you want Squarespace
we even selling you a URL now I'm not
sure if civil war was overrated and we
could do so much better can we please
reboot in phase 4 dot-com is available
but if it is Squarespace we'll sell it
to you
so head to Squarespace calm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to our custom URL in the description
below to save 10% off your first
purchase of website or domain ok here we
go top 10 number 10 Doctor Strange
brought true magic to the MCU with
unparalleled visual effects and action
structured like an intricate
multi-dimensional puzzle that I'm still
recovering from look whereas certain
other insuit films avoid death like well
we all avoid death dr. strange shows us
how death gives life meaning it brings
maturity to the MCU that makes strange a
key role in infinity war in an endgame
and thanks to the multiverse established
here the possible madness is now endless
number 9 spider-man homecoming brought
home a beloved hero just by embracing
what we already loved about him his DIY
ingenuity is Avengers standing and his
hilarious propensity to things
because he is a child mr. stark
homecoming was really a studio when when
but for us it changed the game for the
spider-verse
and for the MCU number eight avengers
endgame of course we all love this 3,000
it delivered endless character payoffs
brilliant fanservice and iconic
fireworks so really it's easy to cast a
blind eye to the indulgent subplots and
some needlessly confusing logic really
in games shield to the self criticism is
less of a film than a climactic event
that half of Hollywood took pardon and
even though other movies on the
solicited structure their scripts a bit
more tightly Avenger sin being fulfilled
all of its promises in more number seven
black panther with obsessively detailed
world building and deeply resonant
themes white panther showed that
representation and diversity aren't
creative sacrifices they open us up to
beautiful worlds beloved characters
heartbreaking truths that challenge the
MCU but also gave it gifts that enriched
other stories it's a shame that that
final battle underwhelmed since you know
that's how so many fans judged this
genre but hey what Conda is the one
Marvel setting I cannot wait to revisit
number six
Ironman kicked off the infinity saga
with so many of its signature elements
heartfelt redemption cutting humor sleek
tech made from box props and how much
fun a binging can be when you weren't
wasting energy on anonymity it's insane
how the oldest MCU film still feels like
it came out last year and that's because
every film that followed is really
trying to do their version of what
Robert Downey jr. and John Favreau
perfected in Iron Man
number 5 Avengers infinity war now
infinity war should not have worked with
leagues of disconnected heroes all
drying in different ways to stop a nutso
cosmos wide problem but the filmmakers
boldly let Thanos take over the
narrative as its inevitable protagonist
or saying everyone else to join a
well-paced Death March of dark twists
and red wedding level gut punches
endgame is the fairy tale ending but
infinity war was the Empire Strikes Back
nightmare cliffhanger that keeps us
Conan had a fear of the plunge number 4
thor ragnarok Taika Waititi
rescued a franchise with much needed
satire but also a
eyes recognition of the revolutionary
themes at the heart of North Smith death
and rebirth ragnerok truly transforms
Thor he loses everything he stands a
woman who isn't into him romantically
and finally he grows as a person also
Ruffalo gets to show off his comedic
vulnerabilities as well as hoaxes even
more hilarious fragile meathead identity
and now after this movie I want to see
spin-offs of everyone in it that says
something number three the Avengers now
look Joss Whedon has taken some hits for
later projects but we cannot forget how
much of a crucial win this first
Avengers was he had an impossible task
of interweaving disparate egos some of
them better known and liked than the
others but like Nick Fury in this film
Joss Whedon combined their strengths and
their weaknesses in fascinating
cocktails to produce a redemptive
satisfying team victory this movie fixed
Hulk it fix Thor by making him a
compliment to Loki instead of the other
way around it introduced Thanos and
whole infinity arc and it gave us a Tony
vs cap spat rustier than anything we saw
in civil war you know you may not be a
threat but you better stop pretending to
be a hero a hero like you you're a
laboratory experiment Rogers everything
special about you me my love the bottle
really Avengers gave the MCU a roadmap
for how to approach Avengers level
threats together ok my top two films
scored the same most days of the week I
love them equally but upon this
rewatched series one has impressed me
just a bit more than the other so first
number 2 Captain America the Winter
Soldier the Russo brothers first emceed
film brought such humanity and emotional
stakes to the MCU that they were
basically given the case of the kingdom
from there forward and rightfully so as
a morally complex espionage thriller it
demands reflection that just because
were the heroes of her own stories
doesn't make us soldiers fighting on the
right side of history
the action is tense this movie burns
down the house so dramatically at first
ages the shield to retitle itself and it
left the ashes of the MCU as fertile
ground for future stories and that
brings us to burn founder crown you know
what it is number 1 guardians of the
galaxy look while Winter Soldier changed
Marvel's game on earth in the year 2014
in the same
here James Gunn did it everywhere else
in the universe to me
guardians of the galaxy has it all a
powerful redemption story about broken
freaks forming a family all set to an
awesome diegetic mixtape with a deeper
level of mystery than we realized
in CU contributions that gave the
infinity saga its whole backstory its
villain and a cosmic aesthetic that
would have made Ragnarok infinity war
and gain impossible without it hilarious
action that escalated into a dance-off
to save the universe like it could argue
this is the MCS first musical first
musical but to top this all off the
reason it gets to 10 out of 10 on risk
folks before 2014 this is Marvel's least
known IP that they were making into a
movie
these weren't Avengers with famous
reference points to just plug in for
Easy fanservice dunks James Gunn poured
his soul into this he taught us about
this family and he made us care about
each of them but more impressively he
made us care about all of them and that
is the direction I think we are almost
excited to see Marvel go in its future
well there you have it my official
infinity saga ranking almost a full year
after the last one of them came out now
I assume you disagree with parts of this
maybe all of it but I don't really care
if you think Black Panther is overrated
or if civil war made parts of you move I
suggest you go back and watch our
breakdowns for the movies you disagree
on the placement of many may be better
than you remember but our next rewatch
on this channel will be Sam Raimi's
original spider-man or watch a long
series continues on discord which you
can join by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA vaz follow the new
rock stars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching boom
[Music]